うん
ん
結果なんですけども
まではずここで実は書けなかったなと言うとまた怒られちまう
かあさんにここは何とかしているぞとかなければどうしようですよ
そうだ実はできたことにしよう
そシロウなっていきますけどちゃんデスノートを作ったんですよ
ノート作ってもうねほんとマジな方で勉強したんですよ水が汚いのはご了承願いたいん
ですけども
ポツポツが似合ってたんですけども
千葉遠いところだと思う増税に際どい所だと思うよ
なんか最近ゲート指は緩いですねというわけでなんとか一応僕の家までの小学校中学校
高校大学ときって学生生活最後のテストが今日ありましたねぇ
複雑な気持ちです複雑ぶっちゃけていうとかけるかけたかっていうと微妙なところです
一応全部目指し勉強
落ちたんで話はわかるんですよただねおいらのその出席日数とかのカメラとかもある
からそこら辺でタイガーというかどうかっていうのがまだ微妙なところなんですよ
本当にわからないまずたい何とかどうか本当にわからないんでちょっと昔のところを
言ったんですけども単位がとれているかどうかはちゃんとこの動画で言います kk
建てるまでもう少々お待ちくださいまあこの後僕が出て社会人になる
かからないかチェストのキックによってなんですけどもなかなかはなしーすねもう学生
が終わるんで大もうなんかヘラヘラもして案内なと思ってきました
いや待て始めここでヘラヘラしたらないったらモールはプレーができなくなる
山ってダメだそうだもっと変でしょ
あそれを話題だいやー
ずっとどうなるのかなで気をつけ今後の話をしようと思います
まあてここで今後の話をしてもしも卒業できなかったら最高に関わるぞ
どうしようここはここはどうしよう
まぁいっかダメだったらダメだからねその時考えるよそれに今後なんですけどもう大学
を卒業して創さんはどこに行くのってよく聞かれるんですけども
まだ決めてませんまだ決めてませんどこに行ってもいいんですよね長候補とした静岡日
増加に続けた東京日中韓羽山渓実感の方に帰るかこの3つぐらいだと思うんですけども
まだ決めてないんでどうでもいいなと思ってるんでどうしようかなーアンケートで
決めるアンケートできるじゃあみんなが受けたておりますると決めちゃう
いやだ人も卒業できるかどうかが決まってから場所は奇妙と思ってくるそんなに焦る
ことでもないので47都道府県で立つでだけ畳にするとかでもいいかもしれないですね
しないけどまぁ書いてあげてしばらくはねなんてすぐこの生活が変わることはないと
思うんですけども手間で本当に大丈夫だったのかなぁと不安なんですけど読めないな
読めない読めないけどもなるようになると思っておりますそれじゃないが具体的に何を
するかっていうのはちゃんと卒業が決まってから話そうと思いますこれまず見知った
ことだって本当に撮影ができなかったらマジかっこ悪いから猫ちゃんと卒業が決まって
からよっ
思いますそれと誰かアーティスト皆様から結果どうだったってよく聞いてくれたので
ロドラルファ
微妙でしたもうマジで結果が呼べなくなってきた部分は撮影ができるかできないか
ポルトガルがにかかっちゃいますましたところで僕が学校で勉強をするっていうのは
今日でおしまいでございます学生が終わっちゃうのか
なんかいろいろ考え深いことがあるんですけどもそれよりね今後何が僕を張っているの
かというのをちょっと気になりますちょっとテストで疲れてるんでゆる異動になっ
ちゃったんですけども学生の皆さん一教でき縁に勉強しておきましょう
大切な時間を過ごしているわけだからね勉強というのはいますけどいないから時間の時
にたくさんやってみてください
いい状況のメインチャンネルでしたね
寂しいあんた匹して学生側の寂しいけど頑張っていきます次回の動画でお会いし
ましょうじゃん